je terminerai sur deux points
est-ce que la vaccination va suffire
pour limiter la cinquième vague la
réponse est non
non la vaccination est un élément
fondamental mais vous savez bien que
dans cette crise en beauce il depuis le
début entre des enjeux de santé publique
et des enjeux d'innovation alors au
départ on n'avait pas l'innovation
maintenant là
j'entends par l'innovation les vaccins
les nouveaux médicaments la capacité de
séquençage
le lait le jeu des grandes bases de
données entre elles et puis de l'autre
côté on a les mesures de santé publique
de mesures de protection soit à titre
individuel soit à titre collectif
on a absolument besoin de l'ensemble de
la boîte à outils il n'y a pas de
solution miracle il n'y a aucune
solution miracle il faut qu'on ait
l'ensemble à la fois qu'on accélère la
troisième dose dont population générale
et chez les patients les plus fragiles
et qu'en même temps on remette un peu de
mesure de protection à titre individuel
pour nous mêmes et en particulier dans
cette période de fêtes qui arrivent mais
aussi à titre à titre je dirais
collectif alors je vais donner deux
exemples
il faut qu'à titre personnel on limite
notre agenda nos les dîners l'ailé les
lélés l'épaule de réception de services
divers et variés vous au sénat
l'hôpital au cce de etc
vous arrêtez tout la
ccc et
moi je dis je sais que ça fait pas
plaisir mais j'ai des amis qui me kim
voulait faire un pot de d'amis et cetera
du cantal la semaine prochaine je leur
ai dit non il me considère comme un un
peu comme un hygiéniste en disant gens
vont soit entre connais pas mais non
c'est pas ça c est on a une période
difficile à passer il faut que au prix
si on ne fait pas ça on sera obligé
d'aller vers des mesures de restriction
plus lourde
[Musique]